[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul and with the boys at an
end i thought i'd look at one of the
biggest comments i see popping up on my
videos that is that black noir isn't
dead dario was right stop we don't
that's all big conspiracy theories and
if you've got the comics then you'll
know he plays a big part in the end of
homelanders story so to have him go out
here feels like a misdirect showrunner
eric kripke also teased that it might
not be the last we see of him in an
interview with entertainment weekly
throughout this video we're going to be
exploring whether he's still alive how
he could come back and also the main
thing that happens to him in the source
material if you enjoy the video we'd
massively appreciate the thumbs up and
also don't forget to subscribe for
videos like this every day without the
way huge thank you for clicking this now
let's get into whether black noir is
dead or not now episode 8 apparently
features his demise with noir being
murdered by homelander this all comes
after noir clearly shows that he knew
soulja boy was his father and that he
now wants to kill him throughout the
entire series homelander has wanted
nothing more than a mother and father in
his life and he even ended up drinking
madeline stillwell's breast milk after
getting jealous over her son
[Music]
you made my
[Music]
[Applause]
therefore this idea by noir simply won't
fly and even though they've been besties
since the day they first met homeland
accuses the potential relationship with
his father over the one that he already
has with his friend now in the comics it
was revealed that noir was a clone of
homelander and that he'd been
gaslighting the character throughout the
entire run noir would dress up as him go
and kill some people photograph it and
then send it to homelander he'd receive
these images see someone that looked
like him with his power set but rather
than being horrified this just enabled
him he never got in trouble for this and
slowly it made him think that he could
do whatever he wanted this led to him
creating a superhero uprising and after
he stormed the white house noir was
given permission to take him down
throughout his life noir had been told
that he only had one purpose which was
to take out homelander if he went rogue
so him sitting around and not being able
to do this is what pushed him to set
things up so that he'd finally be
granted permission to kill him once and
for all now the show set up early on
that homeland had x-ray vision which
kinda negated the clone thing as he'd
instantly be aware of who noir was when
he looked under his mask what he saw was
the deformed and damaged sympathetic
figure that we ourselves learned about
in season 3. that's why noir's death
feels so painful because he's killed
whilst trying to help his friend he
never really stood a chance and
throughout his life he's been overlooked
and used by vote as a weapon this idea
of using people as weapons is reflected
in several characters in the season such
as kimiko and frenchie the two which
were used as a means to an end due to
their skills now there is actually
precedent for dead characters to return
in the comics lamplada nubia and the
bloney [ __ ] were killed in the source
material but they ended up coming back
to life this is because in the comics we
learn v very much supercharges one cells
on every single level even upon death
the formula sparks of the brain and it
causes someone to rise up in a
zombie-like state bought used this to
their advantage in the source material
and after the death of his supes they'd
parade them round one final time this
would be a pr move to show that the
supes were more than human and it was
meant to poke fun at comic books in
general killing off characters only for
them to return down the line once the
parietan public appearances were over
vault would then ship them off and
starlight even came across lamplighter
locked up in the sevens hangar he was
very much just a zombie covered in his
own feces mumbling words and not really
doing anything now in the case of noir
they could do something similar
stormfront already showed us that they
can annihilate a character to the point
that they're barely alive and still have
them somewhat come back from it she was
stabbed in the eye and burned to a crisp
but at the start of season three at
least she was still alive and kicking
well well not kicking but you know what
i mean and noir has already had severe
brain damage and he doesn't speak at all
they could probably bring him back much
like how he was before without people
really noticing all that much however
going beyond that we also know that noir
has something in his brain that makes
him completely subservient to stan edgar
and bought itself during season 2 he was
very much just being ordered by edgar as
he sat in his office and after homeland
took the reign to vote he seemed to
unleash him on maeve now this implant
could be used as a way to control the
zombified version of noir in the future
seasons if he's resurrected then they
can pretty much use that as a way to
reign him in and it would be able to
control his body i'd love it if in
season 4 if he came back as a sort of
robocop type figure that was just being
controlled by whoever is up at the top
of voort much like robocop we could have
him throughout the season getting
flashes of his death and who killed him
this could push him to break free of his
programming and finally get revenge on
homeland air he would still fit in with
the ark in the comics in which noir
kills him but it would just add so much
more to it robocop much like noir is
also a sympathetic figure that was
controlled by a corporation lots of
similarities between the pair and even
the fact that they both wear helmets
that cover their heads you know you know
it could be something they do here it is
a reach as well but moving on now as
mentioned earlier kripke sat down with
entertainment weekly to discuss noir he
said it's definitely not the last we've
seen a black law as a hero it's just
that the guy who was inside the noise
suit in season three he's gone currently
do the voice and you might be able to
tell i've got covered at the moment so
not sounding too good a thumbs up
buttons right there for me soldiering
through now he later went on to say a
character who is completely silent and
in a black mask can be recast so this
clearly hints towards what they're gonna
do with noir and when you think about it
there's no reason to retire the suit
absolutely no one outside of a select
few know what noir looks like and
there's several merchandise
opportunities here that they'd be
turning down if they got rid of him
there's also the fact that no one knows
he's dead and ward clearly had a plan
for how to react if he was ever killed
both super sonic and maeve end up
getting reports running for them on tv
which pay tribute to them but we never
get this happen in the case of noir
clearly vort didn't run these because
they want to keep up the idea that he's
still alive and the next noir will just
fill in the hole left behind by the last
one without anyone noticing
now though i do like the robocop idea i
think just getting in someone new would
be a great way to take things i don't
think they'll go the clone route as
they've already put in place the idea
that homelander can use x-ray vision to
immediately see who it is however he
could end up being used much in the same
way that noir was in the comics namely
as a contingency plan for homeland air
ashley is now well aware of how
dangerous that he is and she could be
recruiting noir's replacement with this
in mind and there's not really anyone in
the comics who matches the strength and
ability of homelander therefore i kind
of get the feeling that they'll invent a
new character for this position everyone
is always wondering who the show will
use for the next season's main talking
point and after stormfront and soldier
boy left massive impacts i'd love to see
things take a new turn in the upcoming
season and walk in and becoming the
focus and with a version of him already
dying in season three it would really
hype things up for the next one who
knows this version might even talk and
he could be used as a wild card to
potentially expose not only votes
secrets but also the truth about the
last black noir lots of things on the
table and hopefully this video has
helped the black noir fans realize that
there is hope we're gonna see this
strong and silent silhouette of him once
more and of course love to hear your
thoughts though so make sure you comment
below and let me know we are in
competition right now and giving away
three copies of doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness on the 15th of
august and all you have to do to be on
the chance of winning is like the video
make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the
character we pick the comments at random
on the 15th and the winners of the last
one on screen right now so that's you
message me on twitter heavy spoilers if
you want something else to watch then
make sure you check out our breakdown of
the fight between homelander soldier boy
and billy butcher such a good moment in
the series probably my favorite so far
and this is just going over why it works
so well if not then thanks for sticking
through the video i've been paul i'll
see you next time take care peace
[Music]
you